E aí
[Música]
e eu acredito que criatividade é uma
habilidade que todos nós nascemos quando
somos crianças
O porém à medida que a gente vai
crescendo somos inibidos de experimentar
ideias novas na verdade somos
pressionados para termos respostas
prontas e rápidas e se me permite
Gostaria de compartilhar algumas
reflexões aprendizados que eu tenho
sobre criatividade
é certa vez ouvi minha mãe dizer que
quando era criança adorava a inventar
histórias criar jogos eu tinha uma
capacidade de passar semanas brincando
depois que assistir um filme e essa
habilidade imaginativa de combinar
ideias era tão presente em mim que certa
vez minha mãe foi chamada de escola para
conversar com a coordenadora digo que
foi a tarde mais longa da minha infância
até que ela chegou e perguntou que
história é essa que você toca guitarra e
você tem uma banda e ainda vai fazer um
Show
é bem na verdade eu tinha uma banda para
o meu vizinho era uma banda imaginária
ele tinha uma caixa de Fanfarra com
disco de vinil velho arranhado preso no
cabo de vassoura e eu uma guitarra feita
com uma paleta de pintura da minha mãe
pregada numa ripa de madeira e é que eu
paro para fazer uma primeira reflexão
e é fundamental para a criatividade que
você exercite a sua imaginação
imaginação é sua capacidade de conseguir
formar imagens além dos seus sentidos é
preciso que você explore ideias que você
combinem e que você quebre padrões a
imaginar é o elemento fundamental para a
criatividade
e diz que houve uma guitarra
o e toquei nela pela primeira vez eu
tive certeza que eu seria um músico na
idade adulta eu sonhava que vai ser um
artista que ia fazer solos guitarra
incrível que é viajar o mundo tocando
além de ter milhares de fã e foi aos 12
anos com Douro com um instrumento
emprestado de uma vizinha que eu levei
que tão a sério mas tão a sério esse
sonho que acabei tomando bomba na escola
é lógico que o meu instrumento foi
devolvido mas algum tempo depois ganhei
uma guitarra comecei a estudar música e
resolvi fazer o meu primeiro show com
isso Eu ensaiei algumas músicas depois
eu fiz os ingressos desenhei no papel
recortei vende e no dia do espetáculo
montei o show no quintal e fiquei
preparando os vizinhos os amigos de
escola aparecerem eu tinha certeza que
ela eu começava tornar o meu sonho
realidade mas foi alguns anos depois que
eu me inscrevi no Festival da escola e
ganhei o prêmio de 1º lugar geral
o festival além dos prêmios de melhor
música e melhor arranjo enfim sabe quem
tava lá na plateia além dos meus pais a
coordenadora aquela que conversou com a
minha mãe algum tempo atrás e ela
comentou é ele é bem que disse que ia
tocar guitarra e fazer shows e aqui eu
faço uma segunda reflexão ideias são
imagens inacabadas podem ser como sonhos
que são inspiradores e te direcionam mas
é fundamental que você tenha coragem
para transformar ideias em realidade
mesmo que se você não saiba muito bem
aonde isso vai dar
bom então pare de ser a pessoa imaginar
ativa e passa a ser uma pessoa que age
a enfim ao completar 18 anos eu e como
muitos da minha idade chega o dia
daquela pergunta fatídica para você que
que você pretende trabalhar a resposta
poderia aparecer a óbvia e rápida Mas
resolvi fazer um teste vocacional e
depois de responder algumas perguntas a
psicóloga me trouxe Como Mágica uma
lista de várias profissões e eu decidi
fazer publicidade e propaganda mas não
Passei no vestibular no ano seguinte
tomei coragem e fiz vestibular para
música e novamente Não Passei no
vestibular aí passei um quase que um
período de um ano sabático refletindo a
resolvi empreender abrir um estúdio com
amigo e comecei a investir no estúdio o
trabalho é bem mas eu ainda tinha dúvida
se aquele caminho era o caminho certo
então resolvi fazer vestibular mais uma
vez só que agora para escola de design
passei então comecei uma vida dupla
estudando de manhã e de tarde de noite
a maioria das vezes de madrugada
trabalhando no estúdio E aí
consequentemente o estúdio melhorava e
as notas e as frequências caíam foi
quando eu decidi então trancar na minha
matrícula E aí eu paro aqui e faço uma
terceira reflexão é muito importante que
você não aceita a resposta respostas
prontas tá é importante que você seja
curioso que você consiga buscar ideias
questione mas é fundamental que você
teste as suas ideias é como eu posso
dizer o vestibular me levou para um
caminho mas eu não determinado antes de
vir para fazer escolhas ter muitas
ideias é bacana mas você tem que saber
fazer escolhas enfocar o que você quer
para o futuro
o pin a vida é profissional como músico
estava indo bem eu tava caminhando
bacana Na verdade eu tava caminhando tão
bacana que resolvi me casar e aí foi um
casar em me mudar na casa dos meus pais
é que eu descobri que a vida real eram
um pouco mais árdua o buraco era mais
embaixo então comecei a me questionar
que que eu posso fazer para ganhar mais
grana
e enfim refletir um pouco mas por que
está tão envolvido em software de
sistema de gravação que resolvi fazer
computação Esse é um novo caminho
trabalhando e também estudando e logo na
sequência que me formei e já fiz uma
especialização na área de design e aí eu
paro e faço uma outra reflexão é muito
importante que você vale de as suas
ideias que você vale de as suas
hipóteses mas principalmente não se
apaixone por elas teste na vida real as
suas ideias e principalmente Aprenda com
os resultados e as respostas que o mundo
lhe dão
e enfim
no passado essa temporada Eu lembro que
certa vez ouvi pela primeira vez o
coração da minha filha batendo no
ultrassom foi um período um dia muito
emocionante mas nessa mesma época também
vive um momento a angustiado eu não
sabia muito bem o que ele era o futuro
em relação à questão da paternidade Será
que eu ia dar conta não ia dá conta até
que recebi um e-mail de uma oportunidade
de trabalho financeiramente era bem
convidativo mas ignorei
e o segundo dia recebi essa mesma
oportunidade enviada pela minha cunhada
e eu mesmo assim deixei de lado eu
estava convicto que eu ia continuar
trabalhando como designer Foi aí que um
terceiro e meio chegou para mim agora de
um amigo do tempo de faculdade bem não é
que eu seja supersticioso Mas resolvi me
inscrever e depois de fazer várias
provas eu descobri que eu estava sendo
selecionado para trabalhar na empresa
comecei ali um trabalho e apesar de
começar como programador e não era o que
eu tinha previsto eu comecei com
programador fui ao poucos aprendendo
mais sobre o negócio com o analista de
sistemas até que finalmente eu comecei
trazer os meus conhecimentos de design
para dentro da empresa e hoje trabalho
integralmente foi essa oportunidade que
trouxe para mim um novo caminho com mil
possibilidades profissionais
ó E além disso me proporcionou de que eu
poder construir uma família saudável ter
a minha casa ter principalmente violões
e guitarras e que que eu faço uma
reflexão nesse momento Nem sempre a sua
primeira versão a sua ideia de projeto
vai ser a mais acertada é fundamental
que você tenha capaz treine a sua
capacidade de adaptar e aceitar as
mudanças que vão ocorrer no caminho às
vezes recuar pode ser uma boa estratégia
para você continuar progredindo que
amanhã do passo a passo no seu projeto
o que sentiment eu descobri que
criatividade tem quatro tipos a usa um
sites criativos eles podem ser mais
espontâneos ou eles podem ser mais
deliberados Como disse um professor
psicologia árbitra o primeiro tipo tá
muito relacionado à questão do processo
criativo dos artistas do músico por
exemplo onde o seu Insight criativo é
muito associado a um dom um talento uma
inspiração Divina o segundo tipo Insight
criativo também de forma espontânea
quando o nosso cérebro inconscientemente
vai buscando fazendo associações
buscando uma resposta até que de repente
alguma coisa acontece de forma aleatória
e externa você que funciona como uma
chave igual a maçã Isaac Newton um
terceiro tipo de criatividade é quando
você de forma deliberada faz uma menção
aos seus sentimentos em busca de
respostas para
Olá pessoal como uma sessão de terapia e
por fim 1414 tipo de criatividade eh
quando de forma deliberada sistematizada
você cria experimentos desta observa
aprendi com aquele experimento E aí você
adapta uma nova versão e vai progredindo
assim sucessivamente o que eu aprendi
com isso é que criatividade é algo que
pode ser sistematizado e vai permitir
que você deixa de ser apenas uma pessoa
imagina ativa cheia de ideias e passe a
ser um indivíduo criativo que resolva
problemas
e por fim a minha última reflexão e
aprendizado é que criativa criatividade
por si só não basta é fundamental que
você saiba responder problemas
criatividade uma habilidade para
resolver problemas então você tem que
aprender fazer perguntas as perguntas
elas promovem o diálogo as perguntas
elas promovem a empatia ela permite que
você ouça antes que você propõe a sua
solução
e é muito importante para resolver
problemas que você esteja muito alinhado
conectado a ele que você entenda
profundamente quanto mais você estiver
conectado o problema são maiores as
chances de você fazer uma entrega de
valor e atender a necessidade do outro
e enfim não faça como eu fiz quando
perguntei como que eu posso ganhar mais
grana se eu tivesse refletido pensado
melhor talvez eu falei a Lia Como eu
posso utilizar a criatividade para
ajudar as pessoas e como ouvir certa vez
não lembro bem quem é o autor é
preferível você responder errado a
pergunta certa do que você responder
certo a pergunta errada o meu muito
obrigado um